مشاهدينا الى
وارسو حيث يستقبل الرئيس الفنلندي نظيره
الامريكي جو بايدن خلال زيارته لبولندا
بعيدا من المقرر ان يلقي اليوم خطاب بن
بولندا حول الحرب في اوكرانيا التي تدخل
ذكراها الاولى وكان عاد الى بولندا امس
بعد زياره قصيره الى كياف التقى خلال
الرئيس الاوكراني زيلينسكي واكد استمرار
الدعم الامريكي لاوكرانيا حتى الانتصار في
الحرب
اذا هذه الصور مباشره من بولندا لاستقبال
الرئيس البولندي لنظيره الامريكي جو بايدن
بعد زياره سريعه لاوكرانيا
اذا مشاهدينا هذه الصور المباشره تاتينا
الان من وصول الرئيس الامريكي جو بايدن
الى بولندا الى العاصمه البولنديه
ورسو حيث يستقبله الرئيس البولندي بعد ان
قام الرئيس الامريكي بعد ان زارا
كياف قبل يوم واكد فيها دعم الولايات
المتحده لاوكرانيا حتى انتصارها في الحرب
اذا مشاهدينا هذه الصور المباشره
من تاتينا من العاصمه البولنديه الرئيس
البولنديه يستقبل نظيره الامريكي في وارسو
في العاصمه جو بايدن يزور بولندا بعد
زياره قصيره
لكياب كان قام فيها والتقى فيها الرئيس
الاوكراني بولودومير زيلينسكي
وبالطبع خلال هذه الزياره في تاكيد
لدعم الامريكي للاوكرانيا حتى
الانتصار في الحرب